[音楽]
今日は弾み社長ですチャンネル東大戦等
ああ
1000万人斬って
5日が経ちました改めて
チャンネル登録をしてくださった皆様応援
してくださった皆様本当にありがとう
ございます
[音楽]
生配信に見てくださった方もいらっしゃい
やクリスマスです強化生産が作ってくれ
ましたねございますチャンネル登録者数
1000万人9生配信見て下さった皆様
本当にありがとうございました
いろいろありましたねまあ今やばやばい
やばいまで行けばいいだけだん
ああああああ
いつまできましたーー
の関係は終わって泣いてしまったり抱いた
ときに流してくださいって言っといた
bgm ですかね
用意してたその後すぐヒカキンさんが来て
くださったり
俺がパパ
水玉リボン度と磨きてな理由はどんな
タイミングで泣き出したり
ねぼくずスッテンっている山田孝之たのは
鈴村愛理さんが来た人はちょっと色々あっ
たんですけれどもあのぜひ皆さんまだ見て
ない方がいらっしゃいましたらぜひあの
見返してみてください本当にたくさんの人
に支えられて僕はこうしてなんか気も強く
勇ましさを迎えられたらかなと思います
本当に皆さん本当にありがとうございます
もう
弾みシャツを目指せ1000万人日本の
トレンド1ずっとなっててイッたあとも
ずっとトレンドに乗ってて本当に最高の形
でチャンネル登録者数1000万にいけた
のかなと思いますとりあえず視聴者の皆
さんファンの皆様そしてこれを機にこれを
機に始め社長チャンネル登録してくださっ
た皆様
今日は[ __ ]
[笑い]
[音楽]
ぬーっ
ああああああ
ってやりたいんですけどそんなにも全く
なくて実は1000万人いくために12月
中はまだ全然撮影のスケジュールが入って
で12月の23に行くと思ってなかった
から全く良いはれていませんと組んで全く
位はいけないや1000万人ってここから
が面白くなるみたいなんで1000万に
行く前にそれやればみたいなちょってるか
もしれないんですけれども当然ある6本
炭してきました気合いが入ったどっかが
まだ伊勢間に入ってから北斗れ続けてるん
でこの気持ちを維持しつつこの後も頑張っ
ていければいいかなと思っております患者
に見えますよガーゼねまき t 生配信2
ちょっとかあちゃんだけ電話出れなかった
かちょっと聞いてみよう感想今与えて
くれるかな
を申しますあオゾン水
はいはいあっ
動画撮ってるんですけど大丈夫ですか
a
ちょっとねちょっとでちょっとだけ
ちょっとだけあの1000万円丁寧なんで
ちょっとだけ
a これ回転可愛い声なんで大丈夫ですか
おかげさまで1000万に行けました
ありがとうございますはい
あのー英語でそうですねなかなか
何だろう面と向かってありがとうっていう
ことはないんですけどいや自分もやって
もらってるよ大丈夫よ言ってるって俺
そんな大丈夫大丈夫
ほんと何か
どこの安っとか批判してくる人よりおぼっ
てくれたのがカチャだったねえ
まーまーまーしゃびねっ起こるしてないと
にあっ
そのおかげで何か天狗というか挑戦に乗ら
ずに
今ドラム調子にならないんでよろしくね
魚鶴ですこれからも追ってくださいぜひ
衛生日々
本当に何か起こってくださる方が近くに
入ったおかげで
なんか頑張ってここまで来れたのかなと
思ってるんで今からもう気を付けて下さい
配置をつけますまあまあまあとりあえず体
だけ気をつけてそうですねちょっと
はいいからちょっと12月は無理したんで
だからもうちょっとちゃま大生マンに行く
ための企画がたくさん残ってるからつの
猛追
本気ねお祝いする暇もなく頑張りました
体だけ気をつけてもんだよねはい
とりあえず
結構
一番レベルで感謝しているのはお母様だと
思ってるのでやったことだます気を付けて
下さいちょっとこれからこれからも一番の
アンチとしてよろしくお願いします
やっぱりいいな彼だか浮かん
お母さんは一般常識的に話ししてるだけ
ですそれがあり方いいのかもしれない多分
だんだんずれてきている
それって苦しいね考え方ねそれだけ
やめようね
良いと思いますありがとうございます z
良かったねはいメリクリデー
[音楽]
なく潰れてなかったろやー
ん
いやー
親には感謝ですねなんでしょ
何コレ1000万人いく過程でちょっと
没頭に捨てたことがあって競らない人から
の嫌なコメントは見ないこれを徹底したん
ですよどういうことかっていうとなんか
やっぱネットで活動してる嬢さ希望通称と
が批判とか結構言われるわけじゃないです
か皆がそうじき歯がとか[ __ ]とか殺すとか
ブスとかもちろん傷つきますけどもうねは
そんなのって俺以外で傷つかなくてなんか
ホっぽいして受け流すことができるんです
よなんですけど意外と魔塔を得た批判とか
生理的に苦手とが嫌いっていうのをなんか
分かる具体的というかあなんか本気でこの
人自分の事嫌いなんだって思うような
コメントとか本気で自分のことを批判して
いるんだっていうのがリアルなコメントの
ものをりっ傷つくんですよでなんか結構気
にしちゃって9年間活動していくうちに家
の中に住所がバレててそれなような人から
すごい弾みシャツをこうあるべ日記だから
こうしなきゃマジでダメとか知らない人に
すごい具体的に何かを言われたり批判され
たりり指さされるのがすごい苦手休館
なんかやん際そうになっちゃってその意見
もすごい大事なんですけども結局自分が
潰れたら元も子もないからなんかある日を
境に応援してくれるコメってが見ないよう
にしたんですよ自分がづらくなるから音が
真に受けちゃってたかそれ普通にやってる
ともうほんとなんかてぐっというかた球を
打つをしてもらうというかなら自分にとっ
てプラスのことだけ取り入れちゃうとかん
かおかしくなっちゃうと思うんですよ人と
してクリエーターとして俺はそういう
知らない人からの気にしちゃうような内容
を見ないようにしてもここまで比較的
まともにねちょっとおかしいんですけど
比較的まともにやってくれたのはそういう
意見を僕のそばでずっと言ってくれた
家族が入ったからだと
胸を張って言えますめっちゃ母ちゃんが
起こってくるんです張飛
なんとまではいかないけどそれはダメだ
あれはこう鍋だコレってどうなのこれって
この人が困らないんだとかこの動画はこの
人が見たらどう思うのかなとかこの使い方
はちょっととか結構グサッとくる意見を
言ってくれるんですよちの母ちゃんはで俺
は何でそれを快く引き受けれたかっていう
と
マーカーちゃんのことをよく知っている
からなんですよ顔も名前も知らない人から
真面目なこと言われてもやっぱり
だけかわかんないから怖いんですよけど
言ってることは合ってるから気にしちゃう
と俺はそんなのみでより名前も顔も知って
いる付き合いが長いってかも家族でそう
いう人からそういうコメントを言って
くれるのが本当に一番ありがたいなと思っ
ててそういうしっかり怒ってくれる人が
身近にいてくれるおかげで僕はファンとお
菓子調査の見てて元気が出る動画のやる気
が出るコメントだけを見てここまで来れた
のかなって思います人って怒られなくなっ
たら鈴木成長止まっちゃう部分大きいなと
思ってもちろん自分で成長できるんです
けど人から送られることってすごい大事だ
なって
思いました
はいという感じですよねが5年各もっと
さあ軽い感じでいこうと思ったんですけど
もうちょっとかあちゃんの声聞いたら泣い
てしまいましたがクリスマスはいこの
プレゼント2000万円ありがとうござい
ます今後の目標なんですけども
生配信に置いた通り今ちょっとないんで
1000万人のためにちょっと12月を
やってきてこの酒まだちょっとよくわかん
ないんですけどまた思いついたら動画で
発表させていただきます今ちょっと設ける
ないそれぞれクライネって米食いて本当に
幸せなクリスマスをみなさんのおかげで
過ごしました1000万人で止まってちゃ
いけないのでこれからも頑張りますので
またチャンネル登録してない方
是非チャンネル登録よろしくお願いします
レザーウェアの12月おれカードゲーム1
回も遊んでないんですよちょっとだけ
落ち着いたら
趣味にも力を入れたいなと思ってます
じゃあんゆっくりどうぞ
あっは
[音楽]
blr